[Music]
cliff kingsbury cardinals head coach had
some praise for his rookie quarterback
in 2019 kyler murray heading into year
number two
said kingsbury of murray via the arizona
republic you're 22 years old first year
in the league and trying to hold on to
your ass can we we've said it and we've
typed it hold on to your ass
it's hard to lead grown men you're
trying just to survive he's on his own
and finding his way as a human being and
trying to navigate it being the face of
the franchise you've got to kind of
understand where he's at these things
just take time so now that kylo murray
has experience of a full season but
holding his own ass along with other
rookie quarterbacks who played a decent
amount last year let's let's look at how
they did
and then let's look at what we expect
them to do chris yeah in 2020. the five
guys that are worth mentioning there are
other rookies who played some but the
big five yeah going into 2020. kyle
murray daniel jones of the giants dwayne
haskins in washington although they have
yet to anoint him the starter this year
gardner minshew the second who will be
competing with
nick foles in jacksonville and drew
locke who
clearly established himself as the
future of the broncos in the final five
games of the season once he was healthy
enough to play
let's let's just who stood out the most
to you other than murray murray
obviously was the best of the bunch
right yeah other than him who stood out
well i you know again i i'm raved about
daniel jones and what i saw during the
year i just was um you know taken back
by
the play from the get-go not only the
pre-season but then when he took over
for eli manning and went out and that
what the tampa bay buccaneers game on a
sunday afternoon
and you know through what he throw four
touchdowns in his first start ever
something like that but good athlete
tough in the pocket can push the ball
down the field to make big throws there
obviously smart so to me he jumped out
and had a great year in a lot of ways
the other guy that i really look at and
just go ooh watch out for a little bit
is drew lock i think you and i both saw
enough there at the end of the year with
us watching games on sunday here at nbc
where we went oh this kid's got
something you know he's got a little
moxie he's an athlete he's a gunslinger
i mean he knows it looks like he knows
how to play so those i think those three
excite me maybe more than the rest not
to say i don't like the rest but they
just excite me the most
yeah when you look at the numbers for
daniel jones
closely similar to kyler murray yeah the
exact same number of passing yards per
game at
232 24 touchdown passes for jones 20 for
murray they both had 12 interceptions
murray had 34 rushing yards per game
and jones had at 21 and which isn't bad
however yeah jones fumbled 18 times
losing six of them which has got to be a
concern moving into 2020. biggest issue
with daniel jones you hit it right
exactly right i mean uh one just not
always having great feel of what what
the chaos is around him in the pocket
which is a good and a bad thing mike
he's he's he's really
fearless in the pocket which is a
strength but it also becomes a negative
there too because he's so fearless at
times people are around him and swiping
at him and he just doesn't even realize
they're there like this is a great shot
i mean jamal adams the pockets
collapsing he's so focused and fearless
in the pocket and focused down the field
that he doesn't feel people around him
you know now this one here you see you
know khalil mack around the back side
that's nothing you can do there but
those are things that to me yes he is
mistakes not positives but easily fixed
not things that i'm like concerned about
to go oh no daniel jones has a fumbling
problem i don't know if he'll correct it
you know i think these are things you
can drill and him just playing and the
experience he got will help him a lot in
these situations
i think gardner minshew has a very good
chance yeah the week one starter in
jacksonville in what appears to be an
open competition with nick foles and i
think nick foles is the right kind of
guy to be the backup even though he's
making 22 million a year he's not going
to complain he'll support gardner
minshew help him every way he can and
minshew played 14 games started 12 he
had 233 passing yards per game 21
touchdowns six picks he had a better
a better passing performance last year
than murray or jones and we just kind of
forget about the jaguars and the whole
gardner-minshew mania thing
died down especially when foals played
again but i think minshu's got got
enough there to make us think that they
may be on to something and and this is
kind of the star that that jacksonville
needs we saw him at the super bowl three
weeks ago he seems like a great guy got
a great win
right yeah this could this could be what
exactly what they need to keep that
stadium full especially with the fans
down there salty that they're going to
be playing two of their home games in
london this year well yes but i'm with
you in the fact of i like what i see
with gardner minshew i do i mean he's
got you know every bit as much or more
physical ability than nick bull of nick
foles to make plays and do that and i
think you're right it's lining up for
him to be the starter you know i think
the interesting thing there about
gardner minshew i don't sit there yet
and go oh he's as talented as kyle or
murray or daniel jones right i don't do
that but i do think he's talented the
thing i really look at is go i think
he's in the best situation to succeed in
a lot of ways i mean it's a pretty good
offensive line you know they got a good
running back they got quiet under the
radar very good weapons at receiver with
dj shark and dede westbrook and a few
other guys there that are good and
talented
so he has a chance to build on something
for sure the thing i ask with you mike
like we know kylo murray i mean to me
kyle murray was the best one right he's
he's the one i think we look at to go he
has the highest ceiling right i mean do
you believe that like he's the guy that
i look at that could be the biggest
superstar of the group are you there
with that absolutely and here's the
thing that that stunned me he was the
rookie of the year offensively and
people were upset like it should have
been josh jacobs it should have been
this guy no kyle murray was under the
circumstances with a bad team in the
toughest division that's what i wanted
to say too right he was spectacular yes
and you know at one point during the
season i said hey look we've seen how
it's played out 2018 year two patrick
mahomes takes the nfl by storm 2019 year
two lamar jackson takes the nfl by storm
get ready for 2020 kyle murray year two
taking the nfl by storm he's got a ton
more experience than either of those
guys had in their rookie years yes and
he's in the offense he's comfortable in
so that's the other advantage he has
he's not serious still filtering through
the nuances of the offense going all
right hopefully i'll know the and be
able to digest this whole thing by year
two he's already there which helped you
know catapult him into a great
leadership leadership position like we
saw with cliff kingsbury and the quote
you read as we came on uh for this
segment you know those things lined up
and you know kylo ren was allowed to be
that guy because he had comfort within
the offense so he could direct people
around and do those things all right so
we say he's got the highest ceiling i
hear here's the other question to me
did did he do the most with less too
right or the do the most with the least
who who who did the most of the least to
me i mean daniel jones i think is in
that conversation as well because saquon
was hurt there was no o'dell sterling
shepherd had some banged up moments
right golden state so i think it's a
good conversation there but i still
think kylo murray probably did the most
with
the least amount of help around him too
i don't know maybe i'm wrong what do you
think well but let me expand that a bit
and say that kyle murray did the most
given his circumstances because maybe
daniel jones had less help but he was in
the worst division in football yeah kyle
murray was in the best division in
football he had to go against the
seahawks toys he beat the seahawks in
seattle for crying out loud that's a
pelt that you can put on the wall none
of these other guys can claim right this
is a an elite playoff team that was
nearly the nfc west champion two inches
away from winning the division and one
of the reasons they're not and weren't
the nfc west champion is a week before
that kyle murray went up there and beat
them in their own building yeah no
you're you're right that's something
that can catapult a team give them
confidence going into year two all that
is a big win there's no doubt about that
so yeah i'm with you i i mean yeah you
could argue that daniel jones might have
had less talent around him at certain
points during the year and all that
you're right but kyla murray's schedule
and the division he had to deal with was
certainly tougher that way uh definitely
now the big thing here i'll ask you why
we're just continuing to go down this
who makes the biggest jump in year two
out of these group of guys we're talking
about because we haven't talked about
dwayne haskins who we saw some really
positive things there towards the end
before he hurt his ankle we were
starting to go oh man dwayne's starting
to throw this ball around everywhere and
starting to look good a little more
athletic than i think we all gave him
credit for coming out in the draft in
those things who do you think makes the
biggest jump in year two
i'm having a hard time reading ron
rivera's comments about dwayne haskins
is ron rivera ambivalent about haskins
or is he trying to keep haskins from
becoming complacent and feeling like he
just has to show up and he'll be the
starter no you have to push you have to
work you have to do everything that the
best quarterbacks do every single day to
make themselves the best and to keep
themselves at that level whether it's
tom brady russell wilson aaron rodgers
the best of the best are working all the
time and i think they want to encourage
haskins to adopt that same kind of i
think you're right 165 day a year ethic
right now i think i think drew locke
fascinates me the most yeah because we
saw him the least relative to these
other quarterbacks but what we saw of
him was great and and chris he lived up
to your billing as one of the guys who
should have been a first-round pick you
know he and any he just you know
he he
he exudes that he's having a good time
he does exactly right what did you call
him beaver cleaver before the draft or
hearing it looked like he looked like
beaver cleaver then he was buzz
lightyear he does the buzz lightyear
celebration when he scores but you know
one of the things i remember about
listening to john madden call games he
always
had an affinity
to the guys who looked like they were
having fun yeah while they played and
there's still that element to it that i
think is very endearing to fans and i
think it just shows a confidence a
looseness that's what it is
he loves the game right he loves the
game and the game wasn't too big for him
right and i remember talking to him
after one of their wins you know the
game's already slowed down he feels like
he belongs and and it i'm excited to see
what he can do
if he's healthy week one and he's the
broncos guy
what can he do for that team yeah
heading into
his second year as a starter i still
think there's a chance kyle murray is
gonna be that guy who takes the league
by storm right but he's starting on a
higher platform maybe drew locke makes
the biggest joke yeah i i i think i
would err on that as well i do i think
if you made me pick the biggest jump it
would be drew lock i'm with you there
mike i mean first off hey i like the
patch trimmers going out there i like
pat schumer the offensive coordinator i
do you know they still got mike munchak
as an offensive line coach i think he'll
continue to get that unit better we know
they got phillip lindsey the big thing
too is you're right we saw drew lock we
saw talent we saw composure charisma i
mean hey come on he went down into
houston and just absolutely obliterated
desean watson and the houston texans
blew them out in the first half like the
game was over see ya done and then they
had the the the guys like cortland
sutton and noah fant who came on the
scene at the end of the year it's like
oh watch out this guy's gonna be a
superstar tight end you know i'm with
you i think drew lock has a chance and
to your point too he does look like he's
having fun and you're right matt and
always used to talk about that and who
do we usually the guys that we talk
about having fun or who you know it's oh
it's lawrence taylor oh it's deion
sanders oh it's brett favre and patrick
mahomes super talented guys who have
great confidence right and they don't
have to overthink things or aren't in
their own brains you know talking to
themselves because they're scared as
hell of the moment and everything like
that and i think that you know i look at
like kyler murray and drew locke and
they have that way about them very much
where they seem unfazed by any situation
and seem like hey this is just like
playing in the backyard when i was a kid
it's no different they i feel like they
have the same attitude either way
every game every drive every snap is a
validation that they belong that they're
good enough and this is going to be
their career and i think that's where
that joy comes from drew lock knows that
the nfl is not too big for him and that
he's good enough to thrive at that level
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports